[Music]
hey everyone and welcome back to our
podcast and the series is called high
school memories my name is l Char and I
will be your host today so without any
further Ado let's dive into today's
episode embark on a great journey
together get ready to be engaged
entertained and inspired today's topic
will be about the one and only the
Masterpiece of H himself the one piece
so for the people who don't know what
the one piece is is the second most sold
comic book in the entire world beating
out famous Comics such as the Spiderman
and the Batman and it's well on its way
to overtake Superman with over 500
million official copies sold now a
little backstory on how the one piece
came to be it's 1997 and the 17-year-old
auter 8-year-old has is currently known
by fans as Oda Sensei started writing
the story of One Piece after the release
of its former lesser known counterparts
known as Roman Z and the most wanted now
the release of One Piece was truly
something massive as no other manga
could stop the massive decline of sales
that the weekly shown in Jump had after
the end of the previously most loved
manga Dragon Ball finished airing now
with a huge amount of manga sales the
large number of anime views that it gets
on both official and unofficial websites
and an average rating of 9.9 on IMDb
and it's recently released live action
version on Netflix which was number one
favorite on 86 different countries
beating our shows like Wednesday and The
Stranger Things One Piece has had a huge
impact on both Japanese culture and on
the Western World now I can keep on
going about the facts that the one piece
has had on our world but I would like to
continue with the story and what the one
piece is actually about now without any
further Ado I'm going to give a spoiler
warning since after this is finished
most of the listeners are going to want
to start waiting what is my
opinion the greatest piece of fiction
ever created now the story follows
Monkey De Luffy and the St pirate on
their journey to accomplish their goals
and I know that does sound childish but
the way it's portray in the story makes
even the coldest Hearts melt with its
complicated characters Marvelous World
building and its beautiful riding now
the main story starts 22 years after the
execution of the king of the Pirates
gold Roger and why that's important is
because during his execution Roger told
the world about his great treasure known
as the one piece and that he left it all
in one place after his speech many
people took to the Seas and became
pirates in hopes of Finding the Treasure
and it as it was said that the one who
has the one piece has everything he
could ever possibly desire we as an
audience first get to the introduced to
our protagonist to a 17-year-old monkey
deffy as he stuck on a wooden barrel and
now he stuck on that Barrel because he
was his little boat that he sat Sail on
got sunken into the sea but now luckily
he was found by the alvita Pirates and
the only true characters with a true
importance on the pilot episode are
Luffy Alva and a young Cabin Boy known
as Kobe now Luffy was let out of the
barrel by Kobe and Kobe thats Luffy's
dream about becoming a Marine so there
was a fight between Luffy because he was
in an army ship and there was a fight
between him and the alvida Pirates but
Luffy takes care of them and takes Kobe
to hun down the P the famous pirate
Hunter known as Ron nooro and now during
the fight with the Alva Powers we get
introduced to the first power system in
the verse of One Piece which is the
devil fruits now a quick explanation
about the devil fruits they are mythical
mythical and rare fruits who give you
special abilities in exchange but in
exchange you lose your ability to swim
and our protagonist has eaten the gumgum
fruit which is which has turned his body
into rubber
now they they go and Luffy and Kobe go
and find R nooro and they recruit him to
his crew after he after he defeats the
corrupt cap Marine Captain known as xen
Morgan now Kobe stays behind and becomes
a marine and so Luffy and his new
Swordsman take to the Seas and the Seas
takes them to orangen toown but wait you
truly might be wondering why did I call
Luffy so at Luffy and that's because we
got a flashback of his childhood now
Luffy was 7-year-old when he met the
infamous pirate Captain red hair chanks
and his crew during one of the meetings
in A Bar Named part's bar luffi a
strange fruit which happened to be his
gumgum fruit after that altercation they
get disturbed by a group of mountain
Bandits which Shanks let go without a
fight but but the hyperactive child
known as Luffy goes to find the B to
find and fight the bandits and get
thrown and gets thrown into the sea in
the process now since Luffy just ate the
devil fruit he doesn't know that he lost
his ability to swim so Shanks jumps in
the ocean to save him and in the process
he lost his arm to a sea king known as
the king of the coast which is like a
very big Angry Fish yes it's a very big
Angry Fish after saving Luffy Shang
gives him a straw at he that he wears
and Luffy promises that he would give it
back once he becomes a great pirate now
in Orange sound Luffy and Zoro
understand that they have no chance of
becoming big name Pirates when they
can't their find their way on their own
so into the Seas so because neither of
them knew how to navigate so enter Nami
an orange head girl who is a thief but
also one of the best Navigators on the
East blue and Beyond even though she's a
thief Luffy decides to team up with Momi
after he defeats the pirate known as
buggy the clown with a navigator they go
to the remote islands where they meet
usab which is the son of yab which is
the sniper of the red her Pirates AKA
shang's crew they also meet Kaa a sick
young girl who gives them a ship after
they do her a favor on her Island and
now the crew G has gained a sniper in
Uso and the ship Nam going Mary now
after they leave the remote island they
go to a sea restaurant known as barier
in there they meet a chef known as Sanji
Sanji is a is a great fighter and a
great character overall and he refuses
to let people go hungry even though they
can't pay now a Sanji refuses to use his
hands in a fight because his hands are
only for cooking now while at barier we
meet Zen a member of the creek Pirates
and we learned that their that their
fleet was destroyed by the warlord of
the sea Hawkeye mihawk and he's coming
to finish the job but the surprise comes
from Zoro as he challenges miw to a duel
as it is his dream and goal to become
the world's strongest swordsman and M
currently is the world's strongest
servman and now Zoro to no one's
surprise was heavily outclassed and got
and got two of his three swords
destroyed and he got a massive slash on
his chest because he refused to get
scars on his back now after the fight a
promise was made by zor that he will
never lose again but his condition is
very terrible as he's all almost dying
by the slash that he gained from mihawk
now a real shock happens when they TR
when they try to leave bartier but their
ship is missing along with the orange
haired Navigator now the crew found out
where she where she went and they
recruited Sanji as they went to leave
and when they recruited Sanji they had
an emotional scene between him and and
owner Z Now owner Z is the owner of the
barier which is the Sea restaurant of
course and now they had that emotional
scene and they left the crew of four set
sail to coko Islands to find their
Navigator and they did succeed on
finding her and now we get one of the
saddest Back stories to date and now I
won't say what happens because that
would be too much of a spoil on this Arc
but I know that 90% of fans of One Piece
At least put the it at least put one
piece on their top five on after this
Arc sorry about earlier now while what
I'm going to tell you is the result of
the arc Nami joins the crew as a with a
with a new found respect for her captain
and Luffy gets his first Bounty of 30
million now there isn't much time to be
wasted so they go to the Grand line the
grand line is an ocean route which wraps
around the entire world which is
separated
from which is separated by the Seas
known as the C bells and it's separated
in two two parts by the red line which
is the only cont continent in the war
piece world and which is a 10 km high
mountain that wraps around the world and
the grand line and red line split the
planet into a cross which is the
entrance to the Grand line
now as the for the col Bells there are
strips of the ocean where nothing moves
no no wind no waves nothing to help you
move but that's not the bad part the bad
part is the sea ganks which are hundreds
of times larger than the normal ones
with the core members of the crew who
example they had to they head to reverse
Mountain which is the entrance to the
first part of the ground line known as
The Paradise before entering the grand
line they do a pit stop to ltown which
is an island near the reverse Mountain
which is the entrance and they get
supplies for their
Journey an interesting thing about
Lowdown is that the there that in
Lowdown sorry sorry I get to distract
you right now the interesting thing
about Lowdown is that it's both the the
birth and the execution place of gold
Roger so with Zoros swords replaced the
cabin stocked with food and the compass
pointing North they set saale and they
enter the grand line while de declaring
their dreams now Luffy Stomps in a
barrel and declares that he will become
the king of the Pirates after him is
zodo and him saying that he will become
the world's strongest
swordsman then it's Nami with her dream
of drawing a map of the world Sanji to
find the all blue which is a sea that
all
that there is fish from all four of the
oceans now last lastly goes usop and his
dream is to become a brave Warrior of
the sea just like his
dad and what's crazy is that I haven't
gone through 10% of the story yet but I
think I should finish the first episode
of the one piece odys here on language
shap perception so thank you so much for
joining us on the first episode of high
school memories it's been an incredible
journey and I'm glad so I'm glad you
came along for the ride until next time
take care
[Music]
here